foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
challenge
yesterday
[Music]
items
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but I feel her
I hear her heartbeat
[Music]
she's so close
so what does her heartbeat sound like
[Music]
mighty
foreign
[Music]
outcast
that's all they see
the way of water connects all things
before your birth
and after your death
with me
and I need you to be strong
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger that doesn't make
sense
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing thank you Spiderman
people still need help Dad that's why we
made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
[Music]
where
are we
gonna come down
[Music]
it's a secret Universe beneath ours
what are you so afraid of
there's something I never told you this
place
it isn't what you think
[Music]
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
[Music]
you help me
so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man
[Music]
foreign
what happened to you
I don't remember
before I knew you I didn't really know
what I wanted in life
and then I mentioned I feel like I'm
going somewhere and I don't even know
where but I just know I want to go there
with you
you ready to tell us what happened to
you
were you alone
I said I don't remember
what I'm trying to say is
you're my person Ruth
what is wrong with you
I love you but people change
Someday I'm Gonna Change
maybe you loved that new version
and maybe you won't
okay
it's just I haven't been feeling like
myself
[Music]
I'm an idiot
I don't deserve these Powers if I'm
being honest like what am I even
contributing
wow there's already a superhero with a
red suit with a lightning bolt on it
Aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and Batman is so cool and I'm just
me
[Music]
I feel like a fraud it doesn't matter
um anyway a wizard gave me super powers
but then everybody got super powers
where's everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
[Music]
you understand I'm a pediatrician
right
come on
the fate of the world depends on it
[Music]
the children told the power of all the
gods
this is very personal Billy
[Music]
look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not super old like
you but I've seen all of the Fast and
Furious movies Lady it's all about
family guys that was a signal
[Music]
the world will not survive this
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I think I know how to fix this too but I
really don't
everyone can be worthy let's give it a
chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
[Music]
whoa
whoa baby clay what is the president
doing in our front yard our entire world
is in grave danger I want you to come
with me on an expedition I'm not my
father he was the Explorer I know you
were just a kid when you went missing
but now you're all we got Mr clade I'm a
huge fan thank you of your dad
where in the world are we Ethan you
brought the dog he just wants to help
yeah
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
uh hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you huh dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa
what is this place the cliffs are alive
and the waters dissolve the flesh off
your bones uh is this thing dangerous
it's so cute I want to merchandise it
[Music]
out there talking to my sons
come on we got a world to save let's get
moving
[Music]
it's just a nightmare tunnel just be
brave
[Music]
dies
no around there yeah
[Music]
foreign
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that I can't
I saw a sign in the sky
I'm ready
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
with you
can't I'm trying to protect you protect
me from what
[Music]
it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it knows how to heart
I know how to survive
[Applause]
whatever did this I can kill it
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the feather serpent God
is killing him will risk Eternal War
we know what you whisper
[Music]
time
show them
Who We Are
[Music]
[Music]
life there was like a frozen River
[Music]
the surface was beautiful
but underneath
it's a joyless and a lonely life
that's you
you are different
[Applause]
you can change everywhere
foreign
[Music]
sorry about the game but we're gonna
have fun tonight
let me guess another it conference I'm
gonna be back in a couple days tops hey
Mom Dad has a work emergency so can you
come pick me up I love it when you call
me Mom let's throw a rager
what's happening
please don't
[Music]
this is so tight
some kind of superhero layer your dad's
a superhero
what no my dad can't handle hot wings
I have a crazy idea
please don't kill me
foreign
Whoever has this technology can do
anything
you gotta save my dad's detective point
and destroy the world
go torture me
dude that was too long that was way too
long
don't you I'm the I.T guy I was alerted
to a security breach
why couldn't you tell me about your
secret identity how am I supposed to say
oh by the way some alien power source
chose me to be the guardian of the
planet
it makes you sound crazy right yes
lifetime's over kids prepare for war
[Music]
hold it hold it these things are warm
yeah so hot you got the winter suit
[Music]
foreign
activity and Battery have all been
charged and are ready for companionship
how do you feel
familiar
[Music]
they are people too they're becoming
more and more aware they need right no
more sex slaves why would someone steal
a companion
it's not a film hunt it's an
organization we're running out of time
Meredith
we need you to remember remember what
dude look at the guy her she said she
ran Meredith off her path on purpose
William told me how you people steal
companions you reprogram them to do
awful things I need to speak to Mary
inventor
she mentioned a man in The Mask the one
who hacked into my dreams she says he
and I go way back
how are we connected
I kind of a minute of your time what's
your name
[Applause]
isn't love
I remember everything
[Applause]
my son sacrificed his life to save me
these powers
are not a gift
but a curse
born out of Rage
[Music]
this Loose Cannon needs to be locked
down
for innocent people start getting hurt
it's been asleep for five thousand years
you find us a cell that can hold them
we'll take care of the breath who's on
the team
I didn't bring a passport we don't need
passports
the Justice Society
we're here to negotiate your peaceful
surrender
I'm not peaceful
nor do I Surrender
here we go
I kneel before no one
you didn't come here to seek Justice
you came to exact Revenge
[Music]
I had a chance
I never said I was a hero
you believe you are not worthy
but fate does not make mistakes
[Music]
you
can be the destroyer of this world
[Music]
or you can be its savior
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
ERS with catastrophe turned out to be
our salvation
the new history of mankind begins here
in these very minutes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and the
Darkness
over the abyss
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that is new glad you guys are still
finding ways to spice things up we're
leaving in five okay
these are the amazing people I'm gonna
be spreading the break with group shot
I kind of wanted to save this prize but
whatever I'll tell you guys now it's a
smart house so I'll send you guys a link
okay let's do this
now you guys are excited told you I'd
come through wow
Andrew Collins you go by Drew right
welcome home
I've been designed and programmed to
cater to your every need so she's like
the house or what most people just call
me Marco
kidding me now go explore this is
amazing come along
I have quite the weekend in store for
you
what is this this entire place is one
gigantic 3D printer
don't tell me you can't handle this
did you hear that this is something I've
been working on for a long time
I've never seen ai's disadvanced what
the hell did you do to him I can't wait
to show you what outside
who wants to party
yet
this is
[Music]
what if I told you
that today
you'll leave here
different
I'm talking
to
you
bro I see someone above the clouds
that's big I'll be big
you think whatever kill pops is out
there
right here
you
are gonna witness an absolute spectacle
[Music]
so what happens next
are you ready
are you ready
good
here we go
I'm talking rich and famous for life
there's plenty of videos for flying [ __ ]
online you know why they don't get what
we gonna get what we gonna get the money
shot what's up undeniable proof of
aliens on camera the open shot you guys
gonna tell me what's going on hell no
cause I'm now here are you the only
person in the world that can get it on
film
a cloud hey move the net it's aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
I'll be rooting for you
I think we pissed them off yeah they
repainted your house
[Music]
they gonna come back
shot
let's go
[Music]
I need y'all to tell me what did you see
in a cloud
well it's not what you think
he took me
they took them all
I'm trying to save you my brother is out
there I don't think they thanked you if
you don't look at it
where you end up with the top of the
mountain
it's the one you never wake up from
you'll be getting a call from my
supervisor asking how my service was
five stars Angel five stars
all right
[Music]
Buzz Lightyear Mission Log Stargate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyperspeed test flight is a go who
are you talking uh no one you were
narrating again I was not just doing the
mission log you do no no one ever
listens to them I know that narrating
helps me Focus
ready Captain light year ready as I'll
ever be Commander Hawthorne this is
exciting a new adventure I'm gonna Grant
you four minutes to be off Planet but
then you come right back to us to
infinity and beyond
anywhere clear for hyper launch
Buzz that was utterly terrifying and I
regret having joined you
Buzz Lightyear to Stark man come in Star
Command
why don't they answer hey
what what is happening right now
sure oh no that's my grandmother but
socks how long were we gone Yum Yum Yum
Yum Yum 62 years seven months and five
days what
I hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
a plan and I have a team Darby can take
any three things and make him explode I
do this and they shave a little time off
my sentence okay and what about you well
I thought this was going to be like a
fan boot camp workout thing
but it is not did I get it pretty close
I need that you don't see the harpoon
[Music]
oh thank you
[Music]
probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2 percent seems
a bit low
failure imminent in three grandma always
says she believed in you too
I think I need a bag don't at least
record your last words do not vomit
inside the vehicle
inside if you're satisfied with this
recording speak or select one
[Music]
to Infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that sorry it's a thing your
grandma and I used to do yeah
increment and initialize
move the pencil
complete this task within the allotted
time if the task is not completed with
an acceptable parameters your daughter
will die
complete
Turn the Page
fill the bucket
found the castle how many more of the
tests are there
Eileen
Eileen thank Roger my husband
what did you do to me
why are you doing this
there's my daughter
[Music]
calm down
I'm very
[Music]
very
good
blue I had a baby that's impossible
hey girl you look just like your mother
[Music]
get her back
foreign
power has now been Unleashed
terrible mistake
the Doomsday Clock might be about out of
time
if our world's gonna survive matters is
what we do now I can use your expertise
you coming or what
a baby Raptor I made a promise we would
bring her home you made a promise to a
dinosaur yeah why
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
where's that biggest carnivore the world
has ever seen
run
see not so bad
[Music]
oat milk latte light foam hey how's the
Mars boyfriend long distance dating
sucks how long have you guys been
together eight years eight years how did
she manage that he checks all the boxes
Oh you mean literally strong jaw mental
fortitude six-pack
we had a plan and then he got his
Martian dream job
so I enrolled in the Mars program
do you ever worry that the wrong person
is headed to the wrong planet goodbye
forever Walt
Z
hello hey what are you doing here who
sticks onto spaceships I can explain
ever since I was a kid I dreamed of
going to Mars you can keep my dream
Alive come with me you cannot under any
circumstances leave my room okay
gonna suck isn't it only for 35 days
you have to keep a low profile
[Music]
all right you guys I'm your captain this
is Sophie my girlfriend long term
girlfriend I don't remember you from
orientation what happened you have to
come right back and just rip his
jumpsuit off
[Laughter]
come on let's go have some fun I don't
do fun you also don't fly on Rockets or
conspire with stone aways Sophie walked
100 bucks says you can send that in your
wrist just kind of face it your space
criminal now
historic journey to make life more
meaningful now that is a story people
want to hear
spent your entire lives trying to check
an impossible set of boxes
I can't risk the plan can you find that
thing that you're willing to cross the
entire universe to be with
make sure it's ready to do the same for
you
my universe
[Music]
it doesn't matter how far you travel you
can never escape yourself did you just
come up with that no [ __ ] that is a
very common phrase
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
can anybody hear me
[Music]
please answer
what if those are the last people on the
planet this is bigger than us
how long can we stay up here growing old
here never seeing Earth what kind of a
life is that we are a group of survivors
if anyone else is out there
[Applause]
haven't stopped it could blow up any
second
[Music]
there's no shame in caring for your own
life Hannah
[Music]
Mrs Wang are you with us I am paying
attention
now you may only see a pile of receipts
but I see a story
I can see where this story is going
it does not look good
what's happening
I'm not your husband I'm gonna listen to
the universe I'm here because we need
your help
very busy today I'm so tired to help you
across the Multiverse
seen thousands of evidence
you can access all the memories their
emotions
about the many verses
and you
maybe your only chance of stopping it
don't make me fight you I am really good
I don't believe you
please
almost really good
he's waiting in the wings the universe
he speaks of Senseless things he's so
much bigger
than you realize
of all the places
[Music]
there is no way I am the Evelyn you are
looking for
that's nature here
this moment
don't let anything distract you from it
[Music]
this work is incredible well that's my
favorite part about taking photos you
wander and find places like this which
makes me a little delirious kind of like
what your eyes are doing to me right now
anyway that's really cheesy no it was um
a little cheesy
um maybe I'll see you here again
sometime
you said he was cute emojis are cute
that guy is melting my sunglasses Tess I
think you could sell this stuff but
there is something that's missing from
like all of your photos you
I love you Tessa
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what is happening when the separation is
dramatic there's unfinished business
he's in the in between he's reaching out
to you
reach back your ghost hunting assistant
has arrived a Ouija board
oh my God I moved sorry that was me
if you do manage to cross and then
suddenly
I'm gonna find him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they say these are crazy times
everyone out for themselves
and one day I got a chance to sell my
soul and I took it
[Music]
would you lie to you with me
[Music]
you know what love is Jack only our
stories from a long time ago
you recently had a new type of
experience like one
without the girl
it's a corporation wouldn't stop until
it has you
the chances to stop seeing the girl
what if I can't stay away from her
then he will die
there isn't much time
in deteriorating quickly
people are very dangerous
walk away
I've never been scared
I'm with you
[Music]
kids get to popcorn now let me tell you
the story of the space Viking Thor
odenson
ordinary man he was a god
ing planet Earth for the 500th time Thor
set off on a New Journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead body
the cardboard
and after all that they reclaimed his
title
as the one and only four
oh speak too soon
Jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's your family three four years
eight years seven months and six days
give or take
for my uh sensing feelings
ones who Gods care about
is themselves
so This Is My Vow
oh God shall die
I was gonna say I was very very
impressive what you did back there
[Music]
it's just my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget you first
[Music]
have something worth fighting for
[Music]
let's see who you are I take off your
disguise and flip
oh you flick too hard damn it
can we helping and eventually grape
[Music]
if you're watching this thing you know
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
usual place immediately shrink Bagels
I've made a shocking discovery
I needed to get me in touch with NASA
immediately well NASA and I aren't
really on speaking terms these days well
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic not crazy
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
NASA
you're the unidentified Source oh yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing I'm asking you
asking you say yes Brian
I need you to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is suit up
you have got a big gravity wave coming
your way you have to launch now does he
say gravity wave
we're underwater guys
oh that's crazy
what's the plan Save The Village save
Earth
let's find itself
wait for it
self
[Music]
[Music]
it's on airplane mode
[Music]
my name's Brian this is my Infamous
inventions Pantry it's actually a Cow
Shed things went a bit topsy-turvy in my
life I was very alone ah Fiddlesticks
that's when I just started making stuff
if any little idea I had I just made is
an egg Bell pine cone bag flying cougar
[ __ ] so whenever anyone in the village
wants to know the time they can look up
in the air and I'll be there
it don't always work and the stuff I
build isn't for everyone but I'm
impressed
my new projects I'm building a robot
didn't look too bad is he I wonder what
he'll do when I turn him on would you
like me to give you a name Tony
Charles Charles Charles Charles
you like that name do you hello Brian
hello Charles it's lovely to meet you
this is incredibly overwhelming
I never thought I'd make everything as
amazing as Charles you built my body's
body and my tummy is a washing machine
and it's time it's a washing machine so
happy together
keep showing them to people
why are you wearing that I feel pretty
cool man imagine I want to go on an
adventure everything is lovely it's not
all lovely stay down boy there's a big
old world out there the big perilous
world oh my gosh
I want to sit in the front right no
you're not sitting in the front you're
sitting in the back I will sit in the
front you'll sit in the back front stop
saying front front front
I've never met anybody that could build
a robot
we're happy
I am not a child I can look after myself
man
I tend to learn from each singing loud
I'm your friend ran I'm your friend
I want to go to Honolulu Charles what
are you wearing
hula skirt
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign